As we go through the following steps
I'll give you intervals in which to
pause the video and
implement the steps on your own project.
Feel free to do this or
to follow the whole video to the end and
try it all at once.
I'll start by creating
an empty project and
then adding a method
called SandboxPlayground.
You can pause here to do this step now.
Now within this method we need to
create an instance of NSFileManager.
This class allows us to find folders,
copy files, remove files etc.
We'll use this to get the path to
the documents folder within our sandbox.
Oddly enough, instead of a URL we're
going to get an array of URLs.
What's going on?
Well, if we think about it,
there is actually more than
one documents folder, right.
Remember, there is one for
each app installed.
This method works by
returning all of them, but
since we are only asking for
one right now,
we'll add in the second parameter to
filter out the ones that we don't need.
Now we have an array with
just the one URL we need.
So let's grab it.
This is a URL to the documents folder,
but
I want a URL to the new
file I'm going to create.
That's pretty easy, we only have
to add the name of the file.
I'll do this now and then you can pause
the video and edit your own code.
Okay, so
now we're ready to save something.
We could use NSData or NSString,
both work in a very similar way.
Let's write the text inside
a string into a file.
There's nothing wrong with being
a little paranoid when it comes to code.
So let's make sure we
wrote that correctly.
How can we find that out?
Let's read it and
see if it's the same content.
So did you try it on your end?
Works?
Perfect.
Doesn't work, check out the companion
text and see if that helps.
So right now we've just saved some data
to disk and retrieved it back, but
this doesn't exactly seem practical for
saving and retrieving tons of data,
many different types of objects,
several versions of the data or
showing it in views and handling
it with controllers, and it isn't.
But what we just did is
just the base concept.
There are frameworks that
build on top of this.
Let's see if Marty and
Doug have some ideas.